I am delighted to hear the buzz in the
room I think it's much of it is related
to the excitement about hearing Michele
later on maybe a little bit of buzz
around being national philanthropy day a
little bit of buzz of the Santa Claus
Parade coming up on Sunday I'm not sure
but I know it's an important day for CFR
it was our annual general meeting today
and we just concluded our board meeting
my name is barb stylist and I'm the
chair of the board of directors and I am
delighted to see all of you here tonight
I think that we've got a great agenda
and I think the salad is in front of you
so please proceed I think we've got lots
to cover so most of you in the room are
very well familiar with CFR we have
about 375 researchers from 17 different
countries working together in our 12
different programs programs on
everything from advancing solar energy
to the genetic components of disease to
of course
artificial intelligence and we've helped
our researchers make tremendous advances
in fields ranging from population health
to the genetics of disease to artificial
intelligence so at sea far score it's
really quite a simple idea we identify
an important research question that
requires knowledge from multiple
research areas to answer and we find
great researchers from across the
necessary disciplines who have the
interest and temperament needed to
collaborate and in the words of you know
some people who may know about human
Synergistics we find a lot of blue
people even though our corporate color
is red so we find people who can get
along with each other and they come
together and they work over a period of
at least five years
they meet they discuss and they take
these intellectual ideas forward in a
very risk-free environment so a little
later we'll be hearing from one of these
exceptional researchers Michele Lamont I
didn't get a chance to say hello to
Michelle earlier but I'm delighted
Michelle is here and she will talk about
her work on how to make societies more
inclusive and I'm looking forward to
hearing her speak again first though we
want to honor two people who've had a
tremendous impact on CFR and they are
George Akerlof and John Haley well the
longtime co directors of our program
called social interactions identity and
well-being and this program was based
upon the belief that judging a society
solely on the narrow economic measures
missed too much of what made life
worthwhile for people and instead
through their amazing leadership George
and John helped us to create a program
devoted to exploring the complex ways in
which health happiness and well-being
are shaped by social identities and
interactions and I'm happy to announce
tonight that both have been honored with
the title of CFR distinguished fellow
the CFR Board of Directors bestows the
title of Distinguished Fellow to
individuals who have made sustained
research contributions at a significant
level of originality and impact and who
have brought brought long-term
participation and commitment to see far
and both of these men richly deserve
that honor first I would like to
introduce dr. Akerlof he is a university
professor at Georgetown University and
distinguished professor emeritus of
economics at the University of
California Berkeley in addition to his
role as co-director he is a senior
fellow in CFR's institutions and
organization and growth program the more
traditional group of economists
drak Olaf received his undergraduate
degree from Yale University and his PhD
from the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology in 2001 he was awarded the
Nobel Prize in Economic Sciences for his
work in the analysis of markets with
asymmetric information and among his
many other honours he was president of
the American Economic Association
he's the recipients of the Kiel
Institute global economic prize and a
winner of the Guggenheim Fellowship
unfortunately dr. Acula was unable to be
with us tonight but he graciously agreed
to provide a few remarks by video so if
you could turn your attention to this
fruit to the screen George will appear
momentarily
thank you I tremendously appreciate this
award but more than that indeed much
more than that I want to thank C far for
everything that you have done for me
over a very long period of time I first
came to see far in what was close to its
infancy in 1990 to see far then as see
far now was speaking to the vision of
Fraser mustard his vision was to put
people with different points of view
together and they would come up with new
and fresh perspectives Fraser mustard
was right I had been a member of 2 CFR
groups the focus of my life for the last
25 years has been on these groups as
they've shaped the problems that I would
working on and how I would approach them
speaking for myself the last 25 years of
my life has been focused on what my
colleagues in CFR would be thinking let
me say a few words which I think
encapsulate Fraser mustards vision my
last paper the one I finished yesterday
concerns the biases in economics my
colleagues in economics are quick to
point to its successes and they say that
they constitute proof that economics is
done the right way but there's another
way to look at it
scientists says Thomas can all work
according to paradigms that may be good
but it means that science also has its
blind spots
the last paper of mine this last paper
that I just finished yesterday then
talks about the blind spots in economics
there's been a lot of head-scratching
regarding my economists did not predict
the crisis of 2008 this last paper of
mine shows that that was no coincidence
it says that economists conception of
what they do created a blind spot that
blind spot made it impossible it made it
impossible for us economists to predict
the crisis there was no way to do that
and follow the prescribed methodology of
how an economist is supposed to work of
course that is Fraser mustards vision
put people in a room together where they
really know each other and where they
can really listen to each other's ideas
and not try to impress one another about
how smart they are and then those blind
spots will be discovered and that's what
see far is all about and the magic
really does happen so thank you see far
you have been the center of my life for
the last 25 years and I'm tremendously
grateful for that and also for this very
wonderful award
[Applause]
I'm sure many people in the room have
have met George and he's a wonderful
individual and and we have had the
opportunity of seeing him in person in
Canada but with us this evening in
person is dr. John Halle well and John I
know is a little banged up from some
truck running off the road but he was
kind enough to get on a plane after a
few weeks and he's a little bit
recovered but John is the professor
emeritus of economics at the University
of British Columbia and he's the editor
of the world happiness report which
annually ranks happiness and other
indicators of well-being in countries
around the globe dr. Halliwell
received his undergraduate degree from
the University of British Columbia and
his PhD from Oxford and he's an Officer
of the Order of Canada an elected fellow
of the Royal Society of Canada and a
recipient of the Queen's Golden Jubilee
award and of the donor prize amongst
many other honors please join me in
welcoming dr. Holly well
[Applause]
I'm very tempted to go into this game I
come out of this game vote the way we
got into it let me ask a survey question
are you happy if you're happy and you
know it clap your hands if you're happy
and you know it clap your hands if
you're happy and you know it and you
really now go back 30 seconds some of
you know that I stopped people at this
point and say this is not about me
singing and us clapping it's us singing
and us clapping you got that be up for
it it if you're happy and you know it
clap your hands if your thank you very
much are you happier now than you were
two minutes ago we have spent the last
14 years discovering why that is we knew
it was true but now we know why it is
true so it was a crazy idea
you got us of even together at Lake
Simcoe in June of 2003 with an idea that
there was room in the social sciences to
take a broader view and we came at it
subspecialists with quite different
starting points by then I had discovered
that this notion of well-being was on
its way to becoming an applied science
there was a whole group of social
identity theorists of whom George
Akerlof was dominant and we had some
very good social psychologists too who
were in the game and all of us
recognized the importance of social
interactions what we didn't understand
14 years ago was that when we married
those three trunks in tried to grow
foliage on top of them it was going to
be very different than we thought it was
going to be so what we thought was kind
of a mini revolution is on its way to
become
a really big one and that's because we
discovered that once you really look at
these three together with the people
from all the disciplines involved they
look very different
so the social psychologists come in and
they were even our group came in this
way saying it's all about us then
distinctions and the robbers cave
experiments that George was talking
about and the Stanford Prison Experiment
so what the banality of evil how easy it
is to trigger people to do something
that hurts other people what the
economic side of course we started off
with the notion that if you wanted to
get people to do something you had to
give them material incentives because
material rewards will what drove them
now both those two it turns out are
fundamentally wrong and they're linked
by something that's one of our key
findings that basically generosity is
stronger and those of you who are here
are all generous so you understand this
generosity is a stronger source of glue
than almost anything else in life and
it's also a stronger support for
well-being and it's it's the underlying
feature that it is societies that work
together and they're unselfish and
giving societies that are the ones that
survive well we've learned that but
there's a long long way further to go
the basic psyche one people still are
told the model I told you suppose the
starting point the basic one people are
still getting there while people as we
now discard discovering are driven much
more and rewarded much more by the way
they interact positively with each other
and for each other and so the next stage
will be to convert that into a broader
and deeper and quite different social
science and what we're doing also and
this is unusual among sea fire programs
is that we are getting much of our power
much of our reach and much of our
influence by direct cooperation with the
people who run schools who run prisons
who run elder care facilities helping
them to use the science to deliver
better lives for people none of this
could have happened
without see farm so to all of you a very
big thank you
John as always thank you your comments
always resonate with me and
congratulations on your distinguished
award congratulations to you and
congratulations to George you've led an
amazing program and thank you for
joining us today
so please enjoy the rest of your dinner
and we'll be back to hear from Michelle
later on Bon Appetit ladies and
gentlemen if I could have your attention
please
my name is Alan Bernstein and I have the
distinct pleasure of being the president
and CEO of C far I hope everyone's
enjoyed your meal and now we're gonna
have a feast and that feast will be
Michelle Lamont oh I'll say something
about in a few minutes but first I'd
like to add my own words of appreciation
to George Akerlof and to John Holly well
as barb Sami has said to you both are
internationally renowned scholars in
their own right and they have also
provided to this organization really
exceptional leadership in in their
leadership roles and social in our
program of social interactions identity
and and well-being and I owe a huge debt
of gratitude to George and John not only
for their leadership and their
commitment to see far and I think
passion for c4 but also for have the
patience to teach a dumb molecular
biologist something about the social
sciences and about identity economics
and if you're happy and you know it clap
your hands I didn't know that song
before John so thank you John and George
in absentia for all your roles that
helped me making see far I think what a
great organization that it is this is
arguably an important and probably
perilous moment for the world
collectively we we all know this we face
many challenges from climate change
income inequality which I think Michelle
might talk about
between and within countries the rise of
populism the refugee crisis or I should
say refugee crises accelerating
technological change the future of work
in an age of artificial intelligence and
smart robots and an increasing distrust
of our most important institutions all
all of these challenges and many more
require research for their solution no
I'm a scientist so you know to a hammer
everything is a nail and so you could
argue I'm a little bit this you know but
I do believe that at their very core we
are not going to get solutions to any of
the things I just listed and many more
without not just evidence for government
but research true research in
understanding what's actually going on
and that requires the world's best minds
to work together towards solutions and
that of course as you as you've heard
and know is what see far has been doing
for the past thirty five plus years
which is simply it's a brilliantly
simple idea bring together the world's
best minds to address questions of
importance to the world and don't do it
once do it on a sustained basis so they
really are creating a safe space to have
honest and deep conversations and ask
the so-called stupid questions where
real progress is made and that's see far
for example one of these questions
centered around understanding learning
and specifically how to model learning
in machines that program which is now
called learning and machines and brains
is of course the origin of the most
powerful form of artificial intelligence
at the moment called deep learning it's
a form of machine intelligence that is
quite simply revolutionary and it is
changing everything from transportation
to banking from medicine to science
itself actually because of our
catalyzing role in artificial
intelligence the Government of Canada in
the last federal budget asked us to
develop a coherent national program in
artificial intelligence both retaining
and attracting
the top people and AI to this country
and within this country to maintain
Canada's lead as a as they go to country
in artificial intelligence and because
of our role and last week's Economist
magazine there's an article called Maple
Valley sounds very soft and fuzzy about
about CFR and our role in developing
artificial intelligence and it really is
I think an example of the power of the
simplicity of the model of C far of
bringing together great people I always
say to my friends who are university
presidents are indeed anybody who will
listen to me I have the best job in
Canada if not the world in academia
because I get to hang out with about 375
John Halle wells or as you'll see in a
moment you'll meet them all with
Michaele limo it is amazing privilege
for me as president to lead this
organization and and have at our
fingertips not only the world's best
researchers but bring bringing them
together in a synergistic way I think
that the point that John made very
eloquently so each of them are great in
their own right but bringing together in
a room together
so that they learn from each other and
bounce ideas off each other
so that they move forward in a way that
nobody could have anticipated none of
the things I think the progress we've
made in our programs could possibly have
been anticipated at the at the time so
and again going back to AI is an example
I think nobody nobody would have
predicted that AI would be worth in the
order a hundred billion or two hundred
billion dollars based on a group of you
know 10 or 15 psychologists
neurobiologists and mathematicians
working together neurophysiologists
working together and trying to figure
out how people learn and mulling it in
machines tomorrow is a is a landmark day
for CFR we're launching our second
global call for ideas so my colleague
John Hepburn here who is our VP research
sleep for the next six months the global
call is an experiment we tried three
years ago which I think was eminently
successful we really are inviting now
the world to come forward with new ideas
for new CFR programs that really address
fundamental questions of importance to
this planet we want the ideas to be
novel bold and potentially
transformative to warrant the creation
of a sustained interdisciplinary and
collaborative program I do believe our
previous call was a huge success
the four new programs that we started
two or three years three years ago now
have really lifted off some of the
fellows from those programs are here
tonight and they are already we're
already seeing huge progress from those
programs so it's now my great pleasure
to introduce Michelle demo dr. limo is
the co-director of CFR's program in
successful societies and together with
her colleague peter hall michelle has
led that program with great distinction
over the past 15 years
she is the Robert I Goldman professor of
European studies and the professor of
sociology and African and African
American Studies at Harvard University
her areas of interest are include
inequality race ethnicity the evaluation
of social science knowledge and the
impact of neoliberalism on advanced
industrial societies her scholarly
interest Center on shared concepts of
Worth and excellence and their impact in
hierarchies in a variety of different
social domains
dr. Lamont was awarded her undergraduate
and master's degree from the University
of Ottawa
so that's your clue that Michelle is I
think still a Canadian and her PhD from
the University the Perrine career Wars
and accomplishments are numerous she was
president to the American Sociological
Association she's a member of the Royal
Society of Canada and a recipient of the
Chevalier or the Lord's Eau de Paume
academic government francais she's a
winner of the gutenberg research award
from the Johann Gutenberg
University the Everett Mendelssohn
excellence in mentoring award by the
Graduate Student Association at Harvard
University and the University of Ottawa
will be conferring an honorary degree to
Michelle I think probably in the spring
convocation if I'm not mistaken and
later this month Michelle will travel to
Amsterdam to receive the prestigious
highly prestigious 2017 Erasmus Prize
presented by the king of the Netherlands
the Erasmus Prize is awarded annually to
a person or an institution that has made
an exceptional contribution to the
humanities or the arts in Europe and
beyond the award consists of a cash
prize of 150,000 euros and I think more
importantly or most importantly she's in
very good company
the former Prize winners include such
individuals as Martin Buber fact love
Havel Daniel Dennett and AS Byatt
they're not in bad company now that
Michelle is receiving this award after
duck doctor elements presentation I hope
there'll be time for a few questions
from the audience please join me in
welcoming Michelle demo
[Applause]
well first I want to thank Allen for
this very wonderful and generous
introduction and second I want to thank
have Eva Cossack because 15 years ago or
so have Eva called me she was then
president of safar and she had had a
conversation with my former colleague at
Princeton Natalie Zemon Davis the French
historian who revolutionized the history
profession by bringing in the study of
everyday life with a focus on ordinary
woman and how history is made from below
and Natalie was my colleague at
Princeton from the time when I was a
NASA sent professor and in a very casual
conversation she mentioned to have Eva
that I existed somehow and have Eva said
oh that's the kind she's Canadian maybe
we can bring her in to see far and that
was 2002 so the picture of me that you
have in your little pamphlet is from
2002 so I was 45 years old now I'm 60
years old now I embrace my 60 years old
but I can tell you that these 15 years
years have been Ladd in company with CFR
for which I'm enormous ly grateful
because now I'm going to tell you a
little bit about my intellectual agenda
and you will see how deeply it has been
shaped by my involvement in the
successful society program and in the
room we have two members of the
successful society program lee han seong
hain and she's here and Ann Wilson I
don't see her I hand so you will see one
of the things that emerge from our joint
work is really or at least for me
working at the interface between
cultural sociology and social psychology
and I have a paper that's coming out in
nature human behavior on November 20th
and it's a paper that tries to develop
this interface between the two fields
that have not been talking to each other
and I think it's a paper that could not
have existed without the successful
society program and I think it's an
important paper but that's just my
opinion
okay so hmm
so I'm gonna tell you about this
recognition gap and what is recognition
I'm just gonna introduce it now for the
time being and you will see that we'll
get more deeply into it as the talk
progresses but recognition is basically
about providing narratives that include
a large number of people define as
worthy members of the society and I'm
gonna be arguing that what we've been
witnessing over the last year especially
in the United States is a growing
recognition gap we're a growing number
of people are now defined as unworthy
and that's really a problem to the
extent that we know that collective
well-being is very much connected with
questions of social inclusion and this
is exactly where the successful society
program meets the program that was led
by George holliwell and by George
Akerlof and John Hawley well one name
two people but the point is it's about
you know subjective well-being that has
to do with inclusion and inequality so
over the last few years we've seen
really a growing number of groups that
have been making claims about cultural
memberships groups that see themselves
as being on the outskirts of society and
they're looking in and they want to get
in so we've had the Occupy movement
black lives matter LGBT groups and in
Canada of course the idle no more
movement of the First Nation in the
context of the last American election
we've had working-class whites who have
been feeling cheated of their rightful
place which has led them to focus too to
vote for Trump
we've had in your
many Muslim wanting to live their life
in public on colleges and college
campuses we've had lots of movements
around microaggression you know the
issue of misappropriation of Korean food
at Oberlin for instance which of course
has been ridiculed by the media but at
the same time what we've witnessed is an
enormous increase in inequality so
particularly since the publication of
Toma piketty's book capital the media
have made us extremely aware of the fact
that distribution of resources is now
more unequal than it has been since 1929
so many citizens who even don't read the
newspaper very often are very attuned to
this growing inequality but the
distribution of resources is only half
of the equation when it comes to
understanding inequality inequality is
made of both unequal resources and
recognition and I want to argue that
while the sociology and the social
sciences our understanding about unequal
resources unequal distribution of the
sources is extremely well developed such
is not the case when it comes to
recognition so what I want to do is
offer a an intellectual and a social
science agenda for developing our
understanding of inequality as a
multi-dimensional phenomenon which
includes which means really developing
our understanding of recognition as an
aspect of inequality so where should we
turn for guidance in the 90s we had two
very influential philosophers excell
Hammett and Nancy Fraser who debated
about the sources of injustice with a
focus on the politics of distribution
and recognition soda pointed toward a
terrain of inquiry where we should take
on the study of recognition and
distribution of material resources as
separate but on interacting dimensions
of inequality which is exactly what I'm
going to do today
so we know that there's a very large
sociological literature on the
achievement gap I'm sure you've read
about this and it's about basically how
to reduce consistent patterns of
disparity in educational measures
between classes between racial groups
etc so I think what we need to do now is
to tackle what I call the recognition
gap which is defined as the disparity in
cultural membership between groups so
some of you may wonder what does
recognition why does recognition matter
is what difference does it make
if people are hungry or homeless is it
only about people feeling good about
themselves well in fact I think
recognition matters a lot so let's take
the example of the poor who are more
stigmatized in the US than they are in
many other advanced industrial societies
so in the American context they
experienced very little compassion and
solidarity and know that the government
does almost nothing for them due to
simply put a lack of public support so
they really feel alone and out of luck
but their plight is not only due to
poverty it is also due to stigmatization
but it doesn't have to be that way
they're viewed as morally worthless
which is quite different than simply not
having resources so we know that it
matters but it doesn't have to be that
way so recognition and it's mirror
cultural process which I call
stigmatization have been shown to have
consequences for a number of very
important social outcomes so for
instance health disparity we know that
racism translates into chronic stress
which has a huge impact on health
disparity between racial groups
stigmatization matters also for access
to resources it can cause poverty think
about parents who kick out their kids b
card because they're gay so these kids
are stigmatized by their parents and
from this results poverty so it's not
always that poverty causes
stigmatization it's also that
stigmatization can cause poverty
stigmatization also counts for
influences the experience of class for
instance whether or not blue-collar
workers feel like losers they don't have
to feel like losers they are not losers
everywhere in the world they are in the
United States but their societies where
blue-collar workers are not viewed as
viewed as losers finally it matters a
lot for politics if we think about the
last American election I wrote a paper
that just came out that shows we did a
very systematic study of the 73 electro
speeches that Donald Trump made and we
looked at all the red buttons those
groups that he talked about the poor
Muslim refugees immigrants Latinos
Hispanics lbgtq to see who he was
talking about positively and negatively
and the article argues that
systematically it was trying to seduce
the white working-class men by removing
blame for their downward mobility saying
that it's globalization that is to blame
for the fact that they are in the
current predicament and that we should
give them job job jobs and then he also
oh you know really reinforce their
status as providers and protectors of
women children and even argue that they
should be protecting lbgtq people which
is surprising and then of course he
zoomed on immigrants and Muslims and
refugees as the gate the great culprits
who are trying to to steal their jobs so
it's obvious to me that you cannot
understand the outcomes of the 2016
presidential election without factoring
the recognition gap and how Trump played
on group boundaries to try to appeal to
this white working-class so the broader
objective of this talk is really to
develop as I said earlier a more
ambitious sociology of recognition and
stigmatization processes these are
cultural processes that can be studied
systematically and empirically
to help us understand inequality as a
multi-dimensional phenomenon but in
order to do this we need concept
measures we need to show empirically
that there's a recognition gap and we
need to understand better the pathways
through which they develop and how they
can be narrowed so how to do this this
is the outline I will first provide a
few concepts I will discuss the growing
worship recognition gaps and changes
particularly in boundaries toward the
poor immigrants and Muslims if they have
evolved in our society under the
influence of neoliberalism then drawing
directly under work of the successful
society program I will explain how
collective well-being can be maximized
by drawing on institutions and cultural
repertoires in order to extend cultural
memberships to a broader range of people
then I will talk briefly about a book
that I published last year with some
co-authors what is directly inspired
from I involve Minh tin the successful
society program which is about how
members of stigmatized groups in the
u.s. Brazil and Israel
experience and respond to discrimination
and finally I'll tell you about how this
stigma Nate this stigma ties Asian
occurs by drawing on a new paper that
compares LBG people with hiv/aids the
obese and african-americans with one
very successful case of distinct ization
one failed case the obese in one mixed
case to try to understand how the
stigmatization occurs so the challenge
as I see it is really to figure out how
to extend cultural membership to the
largest number and I'm trying to give
you a responses to this question by
drawing on three different sets of
questions first I'll show you what
resources people draw on to respond to
exclusion by focusing on the role of
institutions and cultural repertoires
then I'll discuss how stigmatized groups
respond to stigma by looking at what
enables and constrains different kinds
of responses and finally how to
distinguish groups by looking at the
role
of knowledge producers and social
movements so a few concepts
so whereas distribution is about
material resources the German
philosopher Excel huh net defines
recognition as a social act by which the
positive social work of a group is
affirmed and acknowledged by others
stigmatization which is the mirror
opposite of recognition can be
understood as a process that consists in
qualifying negatively identities and
differences so concomitantly one could
define the stigmatization this is really
important as the process by which low
status individuals or groups gain
recognition or cultural membership and
finally cultural membership can is the
status characteristic of those who are
collectively defined as valued members
of a community so now I'm going to
discuss how neoliberalism is shaping
this recognition gap so the first the
second book that the successful society
group program produced was called social
resilience in the neoliberal era in the
first chapter is brilliant co-authored
by French historian Bill Sewell and
Peter Evans who's a leading sociologist
of development they looked at
neoliberalism as a syncretic process
that brings together four different
trends one of them is economic change
such that market mechanisms come to
document to dominate society second the
role of the state in enabling these
market mechanisms to operate unhindered
third what we call the audit society the
process by which we're constantly
gathering data to maximize efficiency
and fourth and least intuitive is the
notion that with neoliberalism comes the
institutionalization of scripts or
narrative through which people come to
understand what defines award itself or
a worthy life and with neoliberalism
comes ending
focus on the notion that worthy sells
worthy people are people who are very
competitive who are extremely efficient
who are very self-reliant that is the
engage in what we call the privatization
of risk taking care of people is not the
business of the state people should be
totally responsible for themselves so
that's the ideal person according to
this narrative of of neoliberalism and
these changes are emerging at the same
time and I would argue that these
changes has led to a growing recognition
gap and this is clear if we look at the
case of France in the US and also Europe
which I will discuss briefly so here I'm
turning to a book that I published in
2000 called the techno forking man and
it's based on interviews that I
conducted with blue-collar workers and
low status white-collar workers like
cell workers cell clerks in Paris in New
York Africa North African immigrants and
French workers in France and African
American and white workers in New York
and in both countries what we've seen is
that this working class as being
experiencing was experienced and even
when I interviewed them a lot of
economic downward mobility defects
perience these killing declining
prestige of their national identity and
even change in gender roles that have
challenged their superior status as
protectors and providers of women and
this has generated a lot of anger in
this group you know the books such as
our Lee Hogg shield or Catherine Kerry
myrrh or John Williams that have been
discussed a lot since the Trump election
are all about the anger of this group so
when I conducted these interviews for
detective working man in the early 90s
these same trends were totally there you
know these men's were pissed but I also
described them as people who try to keep
the world in moral order you know they
are survivors they're people who pay
their bills they're
people who define themselves by their
stability try to keep their kids out of
trouble you know they live there are
survivors they live under very different
conditions but they have a lot of
stick-to-itiveness and they're extremely
proud of it at the same time that they
define their worth in terms of where the
people who keep the world in moral order
at the time I interviewed them they drew
extremely strong boundaries toward
African Americans and the poor who D
perceive as lacking self-reliance
so these moral and racial and class
boundaries really went hand in hand and
at the time I interviewed them they
didn't draw strong boundaries toward
immigrants at all they valued immigrants
especially those who came to the u.s. to
live the American dream so the situation
in France was quite different where I
found through interviews again I did
like 80 interviews in each country in
France you had exactly the opposite
process situation very strong boundaries
toward immigrants who were mostly viewed
defined as Muslim immigrants who were
culturally and morally and compatible
with the French because they did not
respect human rights they treated women
like [ __ ] and they also drew very weak
boundaries toward blacks and the poor
due to the influence of pervasive
influence of socialism Catholicism
republicanism which led them to be much
more compassionate toward the poor and
also to treat ascribed characteristics
such as race as irrelevant now a few
years ago I did an update of this
project looking at how boundaries in
France had changed under the influence
of neoliberalism and we found that they
had changed a lot now the French were
far more exclusive toward the poor they
had they were doing extremely strong
boundaries toward the poor asking them
to be autonomous to be self-reliant just
like I have arrogance we're asking the
poor to be self-reliant my co-author
Nicola given this paper had written
actually a book titled Lewton amigas
assist a and the goal of the book was
precisely to show the ways in which the
construction of the poor had changed
strong boundaries toward blacks now
because a lot of blacks living in
we're now West African immigrants who
were Muslim and the issue of genital
mutilation and polygamy was now on the
newspapers and of course boundaries
toward North African immigrants had also
grown really much stronger than they had
been presumed
previously and in all cases in France in
the u.s. a lot of these changes had to
do with the fact that these groups were
viewed as lacking self-reliance which
whoa which really works hand in hand
with the logic of neoliberalism that I
described earlier and a lot of the
supporters of Lipan supporters of her
for nationally in France were very much
a people who were asking we call them in
French le petit Moya there were lower
middle class the little middle who are
asking the poor to goddamn it pull
yourself by your britches don't be
sponges I don't want to take care of you
take care for yourself
so we also wrote with others of my
graduate students a paper looking at the
broader patterns in across Europe and we
found something quite similar with much
stronger boundaries toward Muslims and
in other countries stronger boundaries
toward the poor so these are macro
changes looking at the American working
class today we know that Americans have
less solidarity toward the poor today
and are more likely to explain poverty
by moral failure than by structural
changes and this is true even among
African Americans who had been
historically far more compassionate
toward the poor so by some account the
boundaries toward African Americans have
weakened in the sense that attitudinal
survey show us that there's less blatant
racism but there's still a lot of subtle
racism what we call symbolic racism at
the same time as patient and
institutional segregation persist a lot
of the schools have become resegregate
'add and boundaries toward immigrants
particularly illegal immigrants have
rigidify as I described and when Trump
in his rhetoric and is elec
all speeches rigidify sins point to
immigrants as the scapegoat he is
resonating with what many American
workers thought were legitimate way of
defining cultural membership in terms of
who belongs and who doesn't
the general point here is really that
neoliberalism is having an impact on the
definition of cultural membership across
societies with more emphasis on
self-reliance competitiveness and
socio-economic success with the result
that you have a narrowing of cultural
membership now turning to the second
part of the presentation I'll talk
briefly about collective well-being and
here I'm in the terrain of John Holly
well different disciplines have
developed different indicators of
well-being so demographers talk about
the least Aetna centric measures low
infant mortality high life expectancy
these are things that everyone agree is
a good thing but you have also economic
measures Gini and Gini index poverty
political measures low corruption what
has defined the agenda of the successful
society group is that one of the things
we've done is really focus on social
belonging social cohesiveness solidarity
as a dimension of well-being and one of
the program members will Kim Lika one of
the Canadian political philosophers who
has worldwide influence with books
translated in 27 languages will and his
colleague key Banting developed this
multicultural index which compares all
countries in terms of what they do for
immigrants do they have courses to help
them learn English how many resources
are put at their disposal
so another program member Irene Blum rad
wrote a wonderful paper which shows that
countries that rank the highest on this
multi cultural index are the countries
where immigrants are most emotionally
and cognitively engaged in their host
society and they're most likely to run
for office here you go Society Canadian
Society as a successful society in the
sense that it really shows
what difference does it make to have
laws but not only laws also the
discourse about you immigrants are
valued valued members of our society and
if you provide such scripts and
narratives to immigrants they're much
more likely to become integrated and to
contribute to the society so a lot of
what our group has done in our second
book social resilience in the neoliberal
era was precisely about discussing the
role of institutions and cultural
narratives as resources for social
resilience and for the stigmatization
and I'll come back to this toward the
end of the talk the point the key point
for now is that laws such as the
same-sex marriage law in the u.s. sends
very clear signals about who's in and
who's out and the same thing is true
about you know tax credits for instance
the things that Trump is now in the
process of doing central to our analysis
is also this notion of cultural
repertoires that send messages about the
boundaries around which the society is
organized so one of the argument of the
book is that societies that promote
collective well-being are also societies
that have a range of criteria or
matrixes around which we can evaluate
who is a worthy person so a society that
only defines success in terms of
economic success condemns the majority
to be losers because by definition only
20% of the population can be a primitive
class but this is the model that we
offer to all the population so what's
going to happen to the 50% who will
never be a pivotal class they're going
to be losers by definition so the
argument is very much that we need to
think socio social scientists
policymakers everyone citizens need to
think about ways through which we can
foster a multiplicity of criteria by
which we can define success in
institutions and cultural repertoires
are crucial to this now I'm going to
turn to this book the getting respect
it's a book that is co-authored with
seven people
the team includes Brazilian Israelis of
course I'm not an expert of this these
countries but what we've done is asked
over 400 people living in Tel Aviv in
and around New York City Rio de Janeiro
and Tel Aviv questions about can you
describe to me an incident where you
were treated unfairly what happened to
you how did you respond and we also have
questions about what do you tell your
kids about how to deal with exclusion or
unfairness and from this we have you
know all these incidents and we use
computer-assisted content analysis to
develop extremely precise understanding
of how responses and experience vary
across sites so an example of the kind
of data we deal with an african-american
man enters an elevator and yeah there's
a bunch of white guys in there and one
of them makes a joke about blacks and
monkeys and he says one of them made a
joke about black and monkeys and I said
man I ain't into jokes his demeanor
changed my demeanor change all the
positive energy that was being in there
was sucked out because of the racial
part I found myself getting angrier and
angrier and then he says luckily as the
elevator doors open there was a black
preacher I reached out to him and I said
can I talk to you because I'm this far
from exploding and then he reflects on
you know am I gonna sue them what am I
gonna do so what you have is a lot of
self-reflection about how he should
respond so we have over 400 interviews
and the comparison looks at these tree
nat'l cases because of course Brazil is
a society with weak spatial boundaries
people blacks and white live together in
middle or lower class neighborhood the
u.s. is kind of in-between but Israel is
a society that is extremely segregated
spatially between Jewish Israelis and
Palestinian Israelis in particular the
study also considered ETOP and Jews
because we are wanted to have black
people in each country and misra Haim
but I won't be able to talk about
that moment in the Q&A if you're
interested so what did we find very
different patterns of responses most of
what they talked about these 400 people
was being insulted but also ignored
underestimated misunderstood there are
experiences that we came to describe as
assault on the self which is quite
different than being discriminated
against because these are not things
that you can sue about so the teacher
who says every morning when I wake walk
in the teachers room no one says hi to
me but they say hi to the white man
walks in with me so it's this daily
assault which really ends up having a an
effect on the health outcomes
one of them says that he is always
misunderstood at work he says I'm a
token no one shares my philosophy no one
confirms what I'm saying ever they don't
understand my tastes they don't
understand anything about me and then he
says they keep making these n-word jokes
with me so typically again these assault
on the self are not things that you can
sue about they are microaggression but
they are much more than that because
they're not all aggression silence is
not me silly aggression so these kind of
aggressions are mentioned far more often
than is destroy nation said then we look
at differences across countries we
talked also about non-response which is
I was so angry so hang angry I wanted to
eat I didn't start a fight I was so
startled I didn't respond so we compare
responses across the five the the five
groups and we argue that black we find
that black Brazilians were twice more
likely to say that they were stereotyped
as poor and uneducated as were
african-americans so for them what
registers first is class rejection as
opposed to racial rejection and we're
gonna be asking why is that for Arab
Palestinians they are perceived as the
enemy within
dirty Arabs there's nothing subtle about
their exclusion none of them complain
about being misunderstood because the
context is such that none of them expect
to be understood
looking at responses they are also very
different confrontation is most popular
in the US by a long
and exactly four out of five
african-american say that you have to
confront compare to half of the
Brazilian and much fewer of the Arab
Palestinian so an example is Maegan
teacher a teacher who describes how she
deals with white people who've cut in
front of her at the supermarket
she says they do that all the time
they're just trying to be superior and
she explains how recently she told off a
white woman when she said to her you do
this not because I'm black but because
you're white because my being black has
nothing to do with you and she reflects
of course it comes as a shock to them
they don't want the confrontation if you
confront them they are not going to give
you a word back because you simply do
not exist you are not there I don't
think she's going to do this to many
many more black women and one woman I
actually put my foot out to trip her so
you really see the anger there so
another strategy that African American
use quite frequently well as F has
frequently as confrontation is what we
call the management of the self as in I
don't want to be the angry black [ __ ]
today I want to be viewed as the
promising lawyer therefore I'm gonna
shut my mouth and I'm gonna before
getting angry I'm gonna talk to my
friends to run by her my interpretation
of the situation to make sure that I am
she thinks I mentor interpreting
correctly so there's a lot of
intersubjective confirmation before
confronting so that's very popular in
the u.s. so few American this is very
important the whole project was premised
on looking at the responses that
neoliberalism enables which are focused
on demonstrating competence and hard
work and we found that this response was
also very very rare among African
Americans which really surprised us but
then when we asked them about their
normative response what do you teach
their kids it was the most important
response they told their kids work hard
study be upwardly mobile consume become
a legitimate citizen that's the only way
to respond to racism so get that card
get that education the proof is in the
pudding your success will be a
demonstration that racism is ill funded
so in the u.s. far less in the other
case in Brazil confrontation no response
and management of the self or equally
salient in part because Brazilian have
much less certainty about what's
happening to them whereas Arab
Palestinians were much more likely to
ignore because they have no hope of
changing anything which is clearly not
what's happening in the u.s. so as
social scientists we want to know how do
we explain that's what they finds the
social science we want to explain so we
developed a you know it's planetary
system that really has to do with
looking at factors that enable in
constraints different types of responses
in different places focusing on three
dimensions and I don't have much time so
I'm gonna go really superficially here
and I can return to those points in
greater depth in the Q&A if you wish but
essentially we focused on historical
background which have to do with how
segregated the society is unequal
whether state capacity exists if they
pass affirmative action law do they have
the bureaucratic resources needed to
implement them a second set of factor
has to do with the narratives that are
widely available and these are not only
the national myths Zionism the American
Dream racial democracy but also
transnational or batch wars having to do
with human rights or with neoliberalism
so they're really the tools the cultural
tools that are available out there on
which people draw to make sense of their
lives and the third dimension is about
rudeness and this is the kind of social
psychological dimension that the group
led by Akerlof and Helliwell have been
concerned with but also other dimensions
which have really to do with networks so
group nurse has to do with how much of
group is the group because of how
frequent and how intense our
interactions within the group but
there's a third dimension which are
describes at
are available concerning what the group
is about you know our white people
necessarily domineering
for instance or are these boundaries
much more fluid so what we did is we
compared our five groups and we argue
that we had to very strongly bounded
groups african-americans and Arab
Palestinians and the three other groups
were much more weakly bounded but these
groups respond extremely differently
african-americans confront most an Arab
Palestinian confront least so therefore
we need to think about causality here
again and to show you how we thought
about this I'll give you an example of
this very elegant black Brazilian woman
who comes back at her hotel at night
after a long day of work and she asked a
clerk who who give her her key so she
can go to her room so instead of giving
her the key she just mentions the number
of her room instead of giving her the
key the clerk takes the phone dials the
number of the room hangs the phone winks
at her and he says he's not there
obviously thinking she's a prostitute
and of course she's extremely upset but
she feels that she cannot confront him
in the interview she says I could not
confront him because he did not see
anything that I could point to to show
that he was being a racist I went to my
room I called my husband who's white
explained to him what happened to me and
he told me to calm down and to go to
sleep so but when we interviewed them
ten years later her ten years later
about an incident where she was excluded
that's the incident she mentioned so the
question then really as a social
scientist we asked what enables this
response so here is our answer we argue
that cultural repertoires of racial
mixture which is very salient in brazil
and emphasized the idea that we all have
a black grandmother somewhere that is
group boundaries are much more blurred
work against the polarization between
groups and lowers the likelihood that
people confront racism by lowering the
salience of racial polarization it
contributes to the greater visibility of
class
criminais ssin these factors enable the
fact that she does not confront just as
is the weak boundedness of black
brazilian experience they think that
their identity is anchored in shared
skin color not shared culture or shared
history this means that the cultural
scheme is about racism that are so
impatient in the u.s. are far less so in
Brazil all these factors contribute to
making this woman far more hesitant to
confront the hotel clerk not having
immediate access to script or tools that
would enable one to make sense of the
situation as a different direct impact
on the interpretation whereas the
african-americans such as Megan totally
are not hesitant to define the incident
as racist she's convinced that this is
about racism this white person who cuts
her off in the grocery store so the
patterns are quite different in among
Arab interviewees what we find is that
none of them use illegal tools because
they think there's no point in a quarter
of the incident that they mentioned they
remain silent or ignored an expressed
emotional detachment in a situation that
many of them see as hopeless so it's a
form of resignation but as a postal
worker states the best ways to stick it
to someone is to actually ignore them so
in this case self isolation is a
response that makes sense it will make
sense in the u.s. but it doesn't in
Israel because you have very high
residential segregation and
confrontation is unlikely to yield
results so unlike Brazilians they really
have no doubt about whether or not an
incident occurred but alternative
explanation are limited by the high
level of group need a group nurse they
experienced the available repertoire so
group disadvantage and the intergroup
conflict and the exclusion that they
face but this does not mean that they
have to confront like Americans could do
given the constraint that they face so
essentially this book is really about
what factors enable and constrain
different
responses which really have a different
direct effect on stigmatization now very
briefly I'm going to talk to you in two
seconds about the last study which is
about the destabilization of people with
HIV AIDS African Americans and people
labeled as obese the first group has
been a great success in this segment
ization in 1980 everyone was scared of
people with hiv/aids it's not the case
anymore we know that from all the
surveys having to do with social
distance whereas the obese they were
looked down at 20 years ago they still
looked down at although there's been
major social movements Tuesday
stigmatized them it's not working at all
African Americans are a mixed case so
with my graduate students we looked at
the whole literature about these
movements secondary literature and we
drew conclusions about why this's and
what we did is that we focused on the
knowledge workers that were involved in
the destabilization of these groups as
you can see for hiv/aids
there were a large number of knowledge
workers who were very deeply involved
and who worked very closely with social
movements to destigmatize these groups
whereas for the obese and African
Americans it was a little bit more mixed
well certainly especially in the case of
the obese so we came up with this kind
of causal path where you have the
cultural resources that are available in
the environment such as you know
definitions of who belongs construction
of stigmatized conditions the social
actors who are involved knowledge
workers and social movements the actions
they get involved in in the outcomes in
terms of D stigmatization so now we know
ok and this is really important because
what we have today is this and here my
my friends from social psychology will
recognize exactly what I'm talking about
there is this very important approach
implicit association test that is being
used for instance by the Chicago Police
Department's they are asked to take this
policeman are asked to take this test
every few weeks and you take the test
and then
they're measuring the speed at which you
associate blackface with good white face
with white and this is supposed to make
you self aware of you know that you
everyone even good people like you or me
we can be racist and this is about to
bring about self reflexivity and in my
university for instance everywhere this
is really widely institutionalized now
by our HR departments and recruitment
committees to try to get people to be
less racist but it's a very cognitively
based approach change your become
self-aware you will be less racist well
I think that this is only half of the
answer my husband also studies this
think it basically it's BS I'm not gonna
say that but I'm gonna say that at the
very least we need to understand the
whole causal path which is precisely
what we do in in our study so the
takeaway is really how does this Sigma
ties Asian occurs it's not only about
asking people to be more deliberative
it's very much about looking at how it
has happened here's the history and how
can we activate the levers to make this
happen again
so what is the conclusion I think it has
a number of sociological items elements
for a research agenda I'm not gonna bore
you with because most of you are not you
know researchers but I think in terms
you know it involves thinking about
causes dimension and consequences of
inequality but most importantly we have
we can think about what is to be done
this is linens question VI linen that is
and we can think about for instance what
can social scientists do well when I was
doing interviews with North African
immigrants in France in the early 90s I
would ask them what makes people equal
you know randomly sample people whose
job were like to clean phone boots - you
know repair roofs really terrible jobs
and they would tell me what makes us all
equal first and foremost is human nature
there's good and bad people in our races
the fact that we all have 9 10 fingers
we all spend nine months in our mother's
womb we all have to get up in the
morning to buy our bread
the baker we're all like clouds equally
insignificant cosmologically they
wouldn't use their words but these words
but that's what they meant we're all the
children of God so ways to think about
universalism that is grounded in
everyday naturalistic metaphors that
people experience first degree so I
think one of the function of the social
scientists is frankly just to diffuse to
be connected and understand how people
who are not PhDs think about
universalism so that we can activate
these levers to try to help bridge group
boundaries and this means you know
trying to get below or beyond the two
silos that so many people are the echo
chambers the fact that the the public
sphere now is you know really pitting
progressives and conservative against
each other and that we're just talking
to people who are thinking of you know
to people like themselves so we really
need to think about how to engineer the
public sphere in a way that we get to
understand better people are not like us
and this involves I think talking very
explicitly about ordinary ways of
thinking about universalism and engaging
in conversation around this not talking
about political philosophy people
couldn't care less we can also think
about what to what policymakers can do
so in the US and this to me this data is
just unbelievable we know that the
states the 32 states that passed
same-sex marriage laws saw a decline of
7% among the high school students who
define themselves as lbgtq who were who
did attempted suicide that's staggering
before the laws it was the rate of
attempted suicide was twenty-eight point
five percent amongst among lbgtq youth
after in those states it had declined by
seven percent because the law sent them
the message of you're among us you're
legit you have cultural membership so I
think passing laws that have messages
about social inclusion is absolutely
crucial the other example really has
do with engineering of collective
identity so I grew up in Cuttino which
was then called Hall just as the you
know border line between French and
English Canada so to speak and I
remember very well when Pierre Elliott
Trudeau in 771 announced that we had the
multicultural society and people in
Quebec were not too pleased because we
were put in the same footing as the
Ukrainians of east central Alberta well
in fact we thought of ourselves as one
of the two founding nations so it really
felt like this was not great but at the
same time Trudeau's gamble worked
beautifully because when we are now
interviewing English Canadians about how
they are different from Americans the
main thing that is salient is
multiculturalism so this is a case where
politician sent very important messages
the engineered cultural identity in a
way that was extremely efficient and
powerful because it resulted in the
inclusion of a larger number so this is
also what politicians frankly can do
manipulate an engineer discourse about
cultural membership that is far more
inclusive and it works through you know
public interest address which we have in
Canada but don't exist in the u.s.
except when it comes to drinking your
milk or something like that so and
finally we can ask what can citizens do
and I like the idea of you know these
Unitarian Universalist churches that
have flags that are welcoming you know
they define themselves as welcoming to
the lbgtq community and we had also on
the lawns after the Trump's election
many signs such as this one who were
really saying we don't want to be a mean
America we want to be a welcoming
America the u.s. is a country of
immigrants so you had a lot of bottom-up
messages about what the society that
people want to live in so I think our
role as social scientists is really to
try to think in terms of collective
well-being and how can we help mobilize
these resources
as these people who put these signs on
their lawns so that as a collectivity as
a community we can you know contribute
to creating a world that we want to live
in but also in which we would like our
children to live in and I'll simply
conclude by saying that for me
the successful society project all the
work that I just described to you and I
don't know if you noticed but there were
lots of footnotes to papers that I've
produced over the last 15 years and
these papers were produced
thanks to see far you know we get
together three times a year there's 15
or something like 15 of us and the
conversation we have have really fed
these papers you know when I talk about
the role of cultural resources an
institution in serving as buffers of
scaffolding for social resilience that's
an idea that we had in common and you
know a lot of the literature on social
inclusion in previous generation had to
be to do with assimilation the notion
that in the 60s there was you know this
notion of what the American white
American dream was that we should all
integrate ourselves in well the model
that I'm presenting here is radically
different I'm saying it's not about all
of us becoming white bread it's about
how to D Sigma ties the groups that are
stigmatized and understand how this
happened as a social process so in my
mind this is exactly the kind of work
that see far as enabled and I think of
knowledge production as a process if
slow process of on the one hand
production and on the other hand
diffusion and what i'm doing here is
diffusion but all of us do diffusion all
the time I had this week a blog in the
Harvard Business Review come out on this
paper on the Trump and the white
working-class and you know who reads the
Harvard Business Review so all of us are
putting our stuff out there little by
little and knowledge trickles out and we
cannot control how it trickles out but I
think it's a process of social change
that is slow but I also think that is
the kind of society
that the CFR wants to stand for and I
would say as a proud Canadian /
québécois that it's also what Canadian
society wants to stand for at a time
when it's important for Canada to give
lessons to the u.s. I think we're in a
good position to do this right now thank
you
[Applause]
Michelle thank you very much for that
really really wonderful
address we're a little over time but I
think we have time for one or two short
questions and short answers Tim the
us-brazil in Israel
why not Canada well the reason we chose
those three cases I alluded to this very
quickly is really has to do with the way
that social boundaries are structured in
those three societies we had in mind a
society that is racially diverse with
very rigid boundaries very flexible
boundaries Brazil and the you know the
walls and the segregation in Israel is
extremely strong and can in the u.s.
thought we thought was somewhat in the
middle we had a conference prior to the
project where we invited some Canadians
from French some Irish people there were
seven cases and when you put together a
big collaborative project like this a
lot of it has to do with who really
wants to be involved so it didn't work
out with the Canadians but Michelle
again I want to thank you for just a
wonderful oh you have a question then
I'll let Lee in a CFR fellow from the
University of Guelph asked a question
the end okay thank you so I'm wondering
if you could say a little bit more about
gender so some of your cases it seemed
like gender issues were very salient if
I think about membership I think that
women are clearly seen as members of
like some of them some of the societies
that you've been talking about if I
think about moral worth often people
think that women are more morally worthy
than men but if I think about issues
around competence and neoliberalism and
being the most productive person you can
be then we start to see gender
differences someone if you could just
say a little bit more about gender
gender is complicated because it's
deeply inflected by class
I think the stereotype is that the
competent woman are the terminal' class
woman Nancy Fraser has a wonderful
meant about progressive neoliberalism
and the lien in argument or the
progressive you know version of
neoliberalism which is that as long as
the glass ceiling is broken by
upper-middle class woman were fine but
in fact this leads the majority of women
trailing so this very much calls for a
much deeper conversation about the
criteria by which the worth of people is
acknowledged so that's all I will say
Michelle thank you very much for a truly
wonderful talk well now I'll call a barb
Sami that's our board chair to say the
last word barb well thank you everyone
for the wonderful evening and let me add
my thanks to Alan's Michaele for a
wonderful presentation and education on
so many elements of stigmatization and
boundaries and and lots of things that
we all try and come to grips with in the
world that stands in front of us a
wonderful evening in tribute to John and
George thank you very much for your long
and dedicated work with CFR and hearing
from all of you reminds me that I
believe in CFR because it does represent
the best that Canada can offer to the
world and we helped to build a Canadian
nation that addresses today's global
challenges and creates a better future
for all of us
this is a very exciting time for CFR and
I couldn't ask for a better time to be
the CFR board chair every time I hear
from CFR researchers I'm reminded of the
huge promise that's offered by science
and of the possibility for all of us to
make a difference I would like to thank
all of you for coming tonight I would
like to thank particularly all of the
CFR researchers almost 375 of you in 17
countries around the world it's an
amazing group their passion to
collaborate and their passion to
discover and solve the world's problems
through science is amazing I would like
to thank our members of the board who
served the organization many of whom are
here today and I would like to
particularly identify Richard Ivey who
is a longtime supporter of CFR and an
honorary fellow wonderful to see you
here tonight and of course have Eva Howe
sack very good friend of Michelle's and
the president emeritus of CFR who led
this institution for many successful
years and as we heard from Michelle was
responsible for bringing her into the
CFR family and I would like to thank
everyone in the room for coming tonight
it's it's wonderful to have so many
long-term supporters that are here a few
new faces it wouldn't be possible for us
to run the organization without your
support and I thank you for those of you
who who are supporters of CFR and if
you're interested in becoming or
introducing new supporters to us we're
always open
come see Alan come see me and come see
any members of the CFR staff so thank
you all for coming this is evening is
adjourned and I hope that you enjoy the
rest of of the season and best wishes
thank you
[Applause]